hello everyone and welcome to live Q&A
on YouTube about go to Korea
we're here with Conan O'Brien of course
you've got a stop shout and sorry you
know what I mean you shout in we're in a
room ten we're in a relatively small
room and there are microphones I
shouting I'm just trying to I'm trying
to be energetic we're here with Jose
Arroyo and Jesse Gaskell right plane
we're here and we're talking about Conan
going to Korea these were the two
writers that Conan chose out of all of
his writers to take with him to Korea
that certainly makes the other writers
seem unhappy I did that on purpose
Jesse Gaskell and Jose Arroyo came to
Cuba and then they came to Armenia the
our trip to the Qatar Air Force Base and
then to Korea so this is my traveling
posse Travis this is how you roll we
roll deep I don't know what that means
where his carry-on luggage or any trip
it seems mean that he would stuff you
into those bags yeah it's to save $25 ah
we're taking your questions again what
you're shouting it yeah I feel like
we're a meeting with the guy that sort
of like this the faculty advisor at our
dorm I'm just excited that's everyone if
you think that he's talking too loudly
please tell us tag and pipe down so
please explain to the people at home if
they don't already know they're probably
not at home probably at work or in their
dorm or in a study hall somewhere
explain why you trace of way driving
mate why did you go to Korea why did you
go how did it all start I went to Korea
because we're always interested in
traveling I love travel shows and we
want to do a lot of them and we had a
build in it before but it really started
with Cuba and then I said these other
shows my assistant Sona and I went to
Armenia we went to Qatar because the
first lady invited us to entertain the
troops there and then I started
realizing I was getting a lot of fan
mail I was hearing from my
from Sona that's getting a lot of fan
mail from Seoul Korea and I thought well
that's great and then someone explained
to me that our shows not on in Seoul
Korea and that there it's a whole group
of people that have become fans of the
show looking at the remotes mostly I
think on on the media social media team
cocoa and YouTube and so I decided well
this is fascinating and one letter
really stuck out a young woman wrote me
a letter on her SAT prep form hi sunny
Lee I don't think in the night I don't
know if she's ever gonna take the SAT
every time she goes to take the SAT she
writes me a different letter and I
really like the letter and she sent
snacks and that is a sacred bond with me
yeah the country sends me crunchy salty
snacks I will go visit you I'm not so
much a sweets person but sunny Lee got
it just right crunchy salty carbee
snacks I love those and that come in
bags that have crazy characters on the
front and you can't understand what it's
all about it's like a moose wearing an
astronaut helmet and so we said let's go
to Korea we were announced we were going
and then we showed up at the airport and
it was bedlam it was it's actually in
the special I've never been that
surprised in my life how many people
were at the airport numbers vary between
1,500 and well over 35,000 a lot of
screaming girls pushing shoving it was
very erotic I I had a blast and we took
off from there and we took Steven Yeun
from Walking Dead and if the whole thing
was as much fun to make as it is to
watch I think and that's really saying
something I mean when people look at
this episode a lot of people have said
this is my favorite travel show so far
and it's because I just think the the
people were fantastic the people of
Korea are funny they're smart they're
they're terrific comedy partners there
they're so open about their
I had an absolute blast I think I slept
for four hours an entire time we kept
the cameras rolling almost non-stop it
was so much to do and it was great
somehow I periscope asked if you Irish
send you Tate OHS will you go yes I
think I'm going to Ireland a little
redundant I actually went to Ireland I
can't remember when it was and it was
the late 1990s I went to Ireland and you
can probably find that online Kony goes
to Ireland and I try to find my
relatives and we just did this cheap
joke but it still makes me laugh as we
put my face on lots of pictures of men
and women from the 19th century and
that's a really fun go looking go look
for that remote it's from the NBC days
yeah that gets all up there I also one
of the jokes in that that I always love
is you're going through famous Irish
Americans with a classroom of children
and you hold up Shaquille O'Neal's
picture and all that beautiful Irish
boys and girls but anyway yeah so I but
I doesn't mean we can't go to Ireland
and really do it right this time
yeah maybe we'll go back absolutely
someone at which some it may be this is
for you too guys was there anything you
really wish you could have put in the
episode that kind of didn't make it or
was there any experience while you're
there that you wish the cameras were
rolling for oh I think a lot of the food
market stuff that we that we shot and
you know Conan trying more exotic foods
would have been great but well one thing
we have to do in the first day we went
to a cat cafe that is just overrun with
there's 40 wild feral cats but they're
just there in the cafe cafe Breda pet
and drink lattes with and that was a
cultural thing that I thought was
incredible yeah I mean to do it properly
we probably have to go back because
there's so much more obviously in Korea
than you can capture in you know an hour
yeah or what's less than an hour with
commercials but but yes that there are
so many great things we probably could
do
we went back which would be great yes
well what was one thing that kind of
surprised you actually going to Korea
versus what you thought about Korea
before you went like one thing you're
kind of surprised by well I was
certainly impressed and I want to say
I'm surprised by cuz I heard that it's
true but I was very impressed with how
large Seoul is it's a extremely large
it's a very beautiful highly technically
sophisticated country their internet the
Wi-Fi there is much faster than anything
I can find anyplace you know our
infrastructure is old and Steven Yeun
made a really good point which has stuck
with me
he said Korea is the only country to go
from a country that was getting aid to
giving aid in like a 40-year span and
when you think about that this is a
country where you're driving through
Seoul and all these incredible in the
architecture is amazing you know it
makes our architecture in Los Angeles or
New York look conservative they really
take chances they're very expressive
they really go for it with their
architecture and I was very impressed
with the the style I mean we talked
about Gangnam style it's true I mean you
look at the way women dress the way men
dress it is incredibly impressive they
have a very good sense of a personal
style and and they're very tech savvy
and we there's a lot we can learn from
them absolutely there was I remember
there was that building you can even see
from our hotel lobby that look like a
giant speaker yes yeah and you want to
explain about the hotel lobby why it was
every morning was so great being up
above everything oh go ahead just gonna
say it was beautiful kids it was it was
on a 25th floor so every morning we'd
all get up and kind of like shuffled on
and then you just are struck with just
looking over the city in this gorgeous
way yes was there any what was your
favorite food that you ate there Jose
because I know is a is a very particular
man
I did I had Jose brought a suitcase full
of his own but yes no I
I tried everything I tried the bin Bob
and was a was a dish that that was
delicious and of course the Korea's
famous for its kimchi which I loved him
she is a cured cabbage secured cabinets
fermented cabbage they have a chili
paste that that goes well with it but
the most exotic thing that I tried was
the the pupa of the silkworm
that you'll see on the show look where
and when coated goes to a PC bang they
open a can of pupae larvae I got
nauseous
and I'm not kidding when he cracked the
top I started to get that acidic feeling
in my esophagus and I thought I might
vomit I be concept the people is sitting
in soya sauce and then you ate it I took
I only wanted to get one cuz I had a
pair of chopsticks but two clung to the
chopsticks so I was committed they were
not a lie they were in a soup of soy
sauce and I just imagined okay these are
just beans I'm eating beans and as I
swallowed some of the some of some grit
on the outside of the pupa started
scratching down my throat and then it
all went sour otherwise wonderful food I
would just meet the pupae later can I
just encourage the viewer
when ever Jose is talking look at how
much he uses his hands I'm saying
healthy what my favorite moments by the
way the entire trip to Korea was know
we're all very tired well we don't work
extremely hard
I mean you most of all and you're you
you are just giving your all and we're
here but behind the scenes of the soap
opera and we're in this dressing room
and you're you're trying get your energy
up so you can do the soap opera thing
and Jose pulls out you want to tell I
have a three by five card holder it's uh
it's made of crocodile skin this is true
by the way this is a truth it's a
crocodile skin three by five card holder
and Conan is always on to me about being
a precious it feeds little European
European Metro section on stantly eating
like a little bit of flan out of a
wooden bowl you know I'd like to make is
that one of the things that I think is
difficult to appreciate unless you were
there when you watch this episode is the
amount of like we're up all the time
we're constantly traveling and to get to
the Academy where I'm gonna learn
Taekwondo just to get there and have it
all set up and then shoot that remote
but then get in the van and get all the
way to the DMZ and then shoot that and
get back and there's there's a lot of us
being kind of exhausted
bus in a van and this is just true of
these of these shows but then we get to
location and you just have to kind of
snap out of it and be fully animated and
on and so I was watching this and you
when we shot the video when we shot the
video for fire no that was I believe I
think a 15 hour shoot or 18 it was
somewhere in there it was an incredibly
long we got there in the morning and we
finished up at like 2:00 in the morning
and the entire time working and yeah
I've never worked that part of my life
and I'm a hard worker and I couldn't
believe how the entire crew everybody's
going all the time and but I look at the
show now and I never see the fatigue
it's so weird I think it's just because
whenever the cameras are rolling we're
having so much fun
that it would be interesting that have
outtakes of all the times that were on
cause it's 20 degrees out we've just
come from the DMZ it's snowing we're all
packed like semi passed out jet lag sick
I was sick like that and the Korean
people found out that I was sick and
they were very worried about my cold and
is this Korea's quota Mike no no no my
son it's my son's fault
giving you high probably did especially
that fire video I mean you sweated
through that sweater like I remember
saying that sweater I've never hated a
sweater my life yellow that yellow
sweater I showed up for the shoot and
usually when you go to any kind of video
shoot they present you with your 35
options yeah and you may have your size
that sweater is several sizes too big
for me and it's yellow now anyone who
knows color knows yellow would be the
worst it brings out and I just sallow
malaria
I'm wearing that and they're like okay
wear that and now dance in his hot
studio overheated studio for 18 hours
and I kept looking out over at Steve and
he was wearing much lighter clothing and
I was fury are but Rowley just before we
started shooting where this old woman's
for home presented Steven with a really
cool outfit yes Steven always and I
always yeah I always look like this
mentally disturbed guy that escaped from
like 1981 you know and even during the
breaks of that video shoot that's when
we went and shot the stuff with you and
Steven with the clog yes this friggin so
even during the break we were just like
let's get in the van and then let's get
something we went down and we shot the
stuff for Steven and I find that claw
machine which was so great cuz the kids
they're they're they are the most
there's God that the young people in
Korea I mean the kids are so cute the
young people are so unattractive
and smut you know funny and I don't know
I just that they were they blew me away
yeah and I think I think to like to your
point about being tired like that's one
of the things that energized all of us
it's like whenever we would get out of
the van or anything there would be a
huge group of people there and would
would give us their energy basically
just be like Popeye spinach and then
going in and you would do it okay or a
vampire draining them yes I their life's
essence so that we can live on forever
Klaus I don't know how to say this name
Klaus harm to boa de Bourgh take a look
at that from Facebook live ass author
motels wants to know how do I pronounce
my lounge yeah Klaus is curious okay
the remote sauce seems so natural and
planned how much did you guys plan
before going to Korea ended Korean
groups secret collaboration as they
heard you were coming this is the first
trip in which you announced before you
went that you were gonna be there yeah
one of the things that is important to
remember and this is something that that
Jessie and is it Hosea yes
it's always been that's it okay wanting
to say Ian no but so but one of the
things that that Jessie and Jose do and
Mike Sweeney who is not represented here
he just creeps people out camera but one
of the things that that these to do
along with Mike Sweeney is they research
so I think the what we get on these
shows is a very nice balance of thorough
research and we all need about what are
our options where could we go what might
fit what might not fit and then
improvisation when we get there and I
think that's the mix you need some
people think Oh Kony can just go to a
country and let's just let the cameras
roll but I would spend three days just
trying to figure out what's funny about
or what are the places to go yeah Jesse
and and Jose and and Sweeney they
research a lot of options and we had a
lot of meetings before we went so
because you can't just show up to a
country and say let's do a que kpop
video that had to be you guys speak to
course of course well for example going
to the DMZ we had to get official
permission and and you know really ask
that some doors be opened for Conan to
get as much access as he got and that of
course takes a lot of work behind the
scenes also that Taekwondo school is
internationally famous they tour all
around the world you'll see it's amazing
they're breathtaking so we had to
coordinate with them as well it's true
it's true all this has been I've been
pointing to your hands
I'm sorry I didn't just a fun game to
play I was singing your praise yes I am
Boris of course Mike Mike Sweeney of
course and Jason should I need the whole
crew behind the cameras play a huge play
a party and things together
no James and Seth and Jason yeah agent
it's exciting and terrifying because you
can do a certain amount of prep work and
we do we do but then you get there and
sometimes all of that goes at the window
and you see what you're presented with
and yes and on this trip I mean we
showed up to Taekwondo and had no idea
that they were gonna do this really
elaborate presentation for us which it's
really funny watching you reacting I was
so blown away but I had no idea they set
up a plastic chair in the middle of this
giant space and that was fun and then
you never know so it's always a little
bit akin to we're we're we're drilling
for oil and you never know like we set
up our but we've what we've learned over
the years is if I'm not feeling it or if
we're not feeling it collectively you
know it's a little bit of a feeling of
yes isn't feeling right this is
obviously impressive it's great but it's
not it's not right for us Korea was
impressive in that pretty much
everywhere we went
felt very good but there was some things
like PC bang turned out to be I didn't
know that PC bang would turn out to be
that funny and that interesting and that
was a natural discovery I had no idea
that they had to do so much on the
keyboard so you see me on camera
watching this guy watch a watch a you
know logging in for 35 minutes and it
really did look like that was breaking
into the Pentagon this new defense boat
launching I mean he looked like one of
those guys in the you know the guy
diehard it's like opening the safe and
that's actually necessary okay you can
say I was sleeping and nothing was
happening when my notice my pillow and I
was actually minding something for a
reason so you lose that one more loss
and you're out of a job learns here but
anyway that was that was so there's a
lot of a lot of preparation and and
these two I'll get your names eventually
these two and Mike Sweeney do an
incredible amount of behind the scenes
work and so that when we go in we have a
good plan which we can then at a
moment's notice throw away just because
of the preparation Sweeney you can join
in okay that's great so what role this
when you want to ask question summer
means UMass how scary was it to be
warned not to touch or go behind the
soldier at the North Korean border and
also what was that experience like and
generally I mean there was a weird there
was a very intense energy in the air I
find this moment more frightening not
unlike this please answer that we have a
very limited time everybody answers
first of all Mike Sweeney does an
enormous amount of work behind the
scenes he deserves credit that's
obviously why he's decided to rush in
[Laughter]
and you thought there weren't enough
great colors that's okay
you look fantastic by the thought to
wear like a New York Mets to shirt I
thought I don't know if it comes across
the North Korean DMZ section I didn't
really I don't know if it comes across
how that really was a fraught situation
it felt you could palpably feel the
attention and and it was also sad like
there was a mean we're making some jokes
but also in a certain point were
overcome with the enormity of you're in
a bus and you're they're telling you
there's a million landmines on that side
there's a million landmines on this side
we're driving through [ __ ] bridges that
are ready to expelled with explosives
yeah I'm ready to blow yeah and then you
get there and Steven Yeun really said it
best he said these are our we're time
when he said this is my family like I
these are my people that live in the
North this is not that's not another
country that's our country we're all
supposed to be together
I thought that was powerful did you talk
about I've you touched on the bus ride
to get to that joint security area yes
we're not allowed to shoot there and yet
it was the most evocative of what's
going on it's yeah no-man's land and so
by the time you arrive at the JSA you're
in the center of the DMZ you're already
just like oh you feel like you've been
transported right there there was
another where was a the bus ride it
started to it was gray it started to
snow we're driving and suddenly you just
start to see a kind of barbed wire we've
all seen barbed wire but you start to
see a kind of barbed wire and concrete
that just looks you know seven notches
above what they put around an urban you
know car rental yeah right and then they
start explaining yes those fields over
there on either side of you that are
frozen there's all these landmines there
are millions of them and we don't quite
know where they are and I said what you
mean you don't know where they are
and or someone asked and they said it's
because when the rainy season comes the
land mines shift that's underground and
basically float all around and then we
have to spend a lot of time trying to
figure out where they are when the
ground hardens in the summer and it's
sad I mean the whole thing is absurd you
know that that this is completely
man-made it was a completely man-made
situation and nothing highlighted the
absurdity more than being in a room
really not unlike the room were in now
where they said if you go to that side
you're on the North Korean side and you
can stay for exactly this many minutes
yes do not touch that guard if you do
touch him he's under orders to push you
both back I've never been in that
situation before yeah and it did feel
like I hope no international skirmish
breaks out while we're on the wrong side
that you're like maybe we would just get
left in there or something well we found
out this show sounds like a riot we were
there showing no but yeah that was they
told us how much I was surprised by this
weenie how much violence has happened in
that area night guards attacking each
other at night and you know think all
these crazy things have happened yeah so
that was very powerful and I was really
glad we improvised it and Stephen I
cannot say enough nice things about
Stephen UN who everyone of course knows
he's this great actor and he's star of
one of the biggest shows on TV he is
such a funny guy he's I've always known
he was funny he's the second city guy is
a great improviser but he's also
incredibly conscientious very Warrens
very intelligent and we really cares
about Korea and really cares about his
people and you know cares about what
happens to that country yes so I we
really lucked out when we asked him to
come and he said yes I feel like we
won the lottery because his presence
makes that show we couldn't have picked
a better I mean I go to any country with
Stephen you and I want to take him to
Ireland it was very conscientious and
conscious of how things were doing would
come across yes it's a different it's a
different culture it's a different
culture and we wanted to make sure that
we respected that culture comedy
sometimes doesn't always translate so
Stephen was our ambassador he would say
that you know this this might be the way
to say that this might be the way to do
that and and having his voice and you
know improvising that the doing and
weather with him that was I think you
know Stephen leicht just over on that
side of the window he's he's really I
can't say enough good about I love that
guy yeah you guys are had a very limited
amount of time on that so we had asked
permission for you guys to sit because
normally you're not allowed to touch the
furniture just like come on it's a
conference room Mike okay you can sit
but yeah you guys had to do all that in
just a few minutes yeah and I don't know
if you get that sense of it and he you
two were brave absolutely all right we
got one more time one more we got time
for one more question from YouTube some
Luque asked do you guys miss Samuel
Samuel actually speaking of improv that
kind of came about just out of oh yeah
that wasn't was to happen yeah just with
emphasis we were supposed to go to that
market and then bought the octopus and
then said oh I'll just take it for a pet
you can immediately see a Korean saying
no you can have it for a pet and you're
thinking I'm on camera I'm saying what
do you care like you know most people
just immediately buy it and drop it down
your mouth it's the equivalent of me
buying a Big Mac and saying I'm gonna
keep it for a pet why does McDonald's
okay yeah so that just happened
naturally a man Jason Shlomi if you go
on the special site you can see how much
Jason Shalini behind the scenes works to
keep alive alive in his hotel
insulting love with the big math yeah
and then now you can that that aquarium
oh I need to take him and go so it was
just a happening in every Travel Show
it's nice when there's one thing that
you couldn't possibly plan it just
unfolds as a storyline and the next
thing you know all of Korea's wondering
how Samuel on the street I'm like oh you
mean the thing that you would have eaten
I wonder if they they took them down the
samuel exhibit as our plane was taking
yeah that'll do it for our live Q&A
thanks for showing up next time be here
on time right exactly
hi I know you were busy somewhere
somewhere there's a naked homeless guy
koco.com slash Korea to see all the
clips and check out our microsite as
well as digital exclusives and make sure
to subscribe to our youtube channel
youtube.com slash Team Coco for more
digital exclusives a live Q&A thank you
watch cutter grit tomorrow night on TV
and drink unless you're lactose
intolerant